after interviewing so many people on  your show what do you think the future  is for relationships between the Sexes  do you think women are realizing they  need to step back into their feminine  uh again I don't really believe in the  the stepping into your feminine I think  you're either feminine or you're not but  I think that families will come together  when there's hard times so I think  whenever they start to pull back the  government handouts I think whenever  they start to change the laws and  whenever they start to bail stop bailing  women out of their bad decisions you  know women were opportunistic so as soon  as they stopped bailing us out then we  find something